the 707 special mission group is an
elite counterterrorism unit of the
Republic of Korea Army Special Warfare
command not long after the Munich
Massacre occurred
the South Korean government realized the
importance of having a counterterrorism
unit so just before the commencement of
the 1988 Olympics the 707 was created
consisting of around 200 men and women
this enterprise is organized into two
assault companies one in a support role
and the other a female only unit which
focuses on personal protection and low
visibility operations this unit is South
Korea's primary counterterrorism and
Quick Reaction Force these soldiers once
distinguished by their black berets
frequently conduct anti-terrorism
missions and are considered the Army's
Quick Reaction Force during emergencies
the unit's nickname is the white tiger
in February 2000 nineteen the 707
special mission battalion was
reorganized and renamed into the 77th
special mission group when additional
personnel and equipment was required to
ensure greater preparation against
various threats the recruitment process
usually involves soldiers from a number
of different branches within the Korean
Armed Forces who apply in attempt to
become members of the elite force others
are handpicked by the superiors across
many different branches of the military
the selection process is very rigorous
in applicants were first undergo a
background check and later attend a
process of which 90% are eliminated
after the reactivation of team rainbow
2015 to 7 o 7th group operators were
recruited to bring their skills and
expertise to assist in the fight against
terrorism on a global scale these agents
were called dhoka b and vigil
[Music]
you
your phone Israeli here let me get that
for you
[Music]
grace nam codenamed doe kirby is an
attacking operator and team rainbow doe
kirby has always stood out from the rest
of the crowd it had a natural talent of
surpassing others limited expectations
of her her skills were voiced late
predominantly in science and technology
and as a young person she often focused
a lot of their time scavenging and
buying spare components to build her own
computer not one to shy away from a
physical challenge she regularly joined
the local neighborhood boys playing
football and repeatedly got into brawls
with them nevertheless she always
managed to hold her own oftentimes in
school her sharp tongue landed her in
trouble with the teachers and because
she looked like and acted like a
troublemaker
they tried to force her into conforming
to societal expectations
Doka be new in order to survive and
clearly excel in this environment she
would need to learn how to carefully
manipulate others and play off their own
preconceptions of her and how she should
behave she worked hard to further
enhance her facade adopting a meek geeky
girl persona and even going as far to
purchase fake lusts while her skills and
intelligence attend to a national
scholarship at the Korea advanced
Institute of Science and Technology
not long after graduating she decided to
join the army from here who daredevil
nature and natural athletic ability paid
off and before long she was assigned to
the Republic of the Korean army Special
Warfare command she later earned a place
within the ninth Special Forces Brigade
known as the ghosts
despite her unconventional behavior and
the highly regimented Republic of Korea
army she gained notoriety for exemplary
tech skills and high adaptability in
situations while participating in a
joint exercise with the detachment K
Green Berets her American instructors
encouraged to a tryout for the white
tigers although the white tigers were a
much better fit for his skills doping
inadvertedly butted heads with major
general car with political ties to the
blue house this old guard soldier
followed orders to the T and expected
the same along with unflinching loyalty
from his battalion with the two
continuously locking horns car was able
to make life incredibly difficult for
dr. B and was callously preventing it
from reaching their full potential
during a training exercise with the SAS
she heard about rainbow and knew this
sounded like the opportunity she'd been
searching for it was finally a chance to
demonstrate her strengths Doka b new
major-general Kerr would never put her
name Ford if you really want this she
would have to do it on her own so she
did what she always said thought outside
the box and in the end was rewarded she
is now a member of Team rainbow much to
the surprise and discontent of the major
he wants her out of the white tigers and
any slip-up at this point could see it
drummed out of the military entirely doe
kirby is finally among men and woman who
encourage unorthodox ideas and even
though she knows she has a target on her
back she could not be happier
Rainbow six has been a most daring stunt
so far and she knows she's alienating
herself from the Korean military and
this with the added pressure to perform
and proof and succeed is what drives her
dough Kirby plays with others perceived
expectations because she wants people to
underestimate it but it's different with
rainbow she needs to work twice as hard
and she wants to work twice a cert even
more so as she assured the other
Republic of Korea operator vigil is
spying on
Doka B uses the ballistic armor military
laptop codenamed
logic bomb it is used to hack enemy PDA
devices the program downloads virus
affecting in bypass firewalls turning
surrounding devices on and emitting a
loud noise to compromise the enemy's
position the program is short and self
erasing to prevent anyone from
unraveling the code and building
software to counter
you never saw me coming
don't feel so bad nobody ever sees me I
mean everyone's blind spot shawl
kyung-hwa codenamed vigil is a defending
operator and team rainbow vigil
remembers very little of his childhood
he remembers fleeing with his family
across Asia as refugees or were there
criminals he remembers his older brother
drowning while crossing a large river he
remembers the safe house they remain
trapped in for over a month in the
Assads
he remembers their train ride we
soldiers apprehended two fellow
castaways he remembers his sick mother
slowing them down while crossing the
jungle he remembers them leaving her
behind his father ordering him not to
cry as the slightest sound could Alert
nearby patrols they eventually reached
South Korea where they were given asylum
but this unfortunately was not the happy
life that they'd foreseen the loss of
his family proved too much for his
father and not long after arriving he
took his own life leaving a son all
alone
throughout this time vigil remainder
stone never showing emotion never
revealing his inner thoughts and keeping
the memory of his family safe adopted by
the wire family who believed to be best
that he forgot his past they immediately
changed his full name - Charu Anwar this
was just another form of camouflage with
vigil another layer to protect himself
from the outside world
so naturally he obliged he was now
growing up in a system of rules and
codes of conduct and these provided him
with stability a reason to be stuck a
requirement to follow orders rules he
could hide behind rules kept you alive
from his biological parents to the wire
family the people in his life
continually emphasized the importance of
keeping to oneself and that any abnormal
behavior could draw unnecessary
attention because shame to the family
could even mean the difference between
life and death
he had strong admiration and devotion
towards the country that had taken a
minute and desperately wanted to give
back to South Korea so we entered the
Republic of Korea Navy earning a berth
in the Navy he proved to be an exemplary
sailor not only passing with distinction
but also becoming an exemplary operator
because of this he was specifically
handpicked by the 707 the special
mission battalion white tigers he was
hardworking methodical and determined
although a bit quiet and when South
Korea was given the opportunity to seem
to operators to rainbow vigil was
without a question at the top of the
list while the highly effective and
competent operator is very much
uncomfortable in social situations he is
anxious others may see through his walls
and that his expressions in body
language may inevitably give him away he
feels exposed like an open book that
might betray all the secrets and this
may explain while vigil is most
comfortable wearing his ballistic mask
he can hide so he can breathe and it
serves as another important layer of
protection
vigils quiet lethality in the field
allows them to rely on his electronic
rendering cloak the ER c7 uses two most
reality technology to remove perceivable
stimuli from a strict environment vigil
carries a prototype in his backpack
which scans surrounding electronic
devices and wipes his image from any
cameras in view I personally enjoyed
these background stories especially
vigils so kudos to the writers for the
work on these I may have slightly
tweaked them and put a small amount of
my own spin to help to get the raw
emotion across but the base story stayed
the same from here I'll be tackling some
of the solo operators like worden etc so
the videos will be a little shorter but
hopefully I'll be able to get them out a
little more often anyway thank you very
much for watching and I'll catch you
next one Cheers